question ouverte hier d'une tristesse
c'est pas ton habitude
qu'est ce qui t'a dit si tu savais que
ce qui m'arrive si tu savais que ce qui
m'arrive
qu'est ce qui t'arrive ça perdu ton
travail
locke est perdu il avait même pas trouvé
d'abord je cherche même pas alors on
sais pas je ne veux pas chercher jeu
alors qu'est ce que tu veux si tu savais
qu est ce qui m'arrive site
si tu me dis pas ce qui t'arrive ne
saurai jamais je crois que ma femme elle
me trompe je crois ou ai-je en est sûr
je crois que j'en suis sûr étant la
preuve
et ouais elle a avoué à vous et allez tu
crois toi tout ce que les femmes disent
je crois pas quand est-ce que mme otis
le prix d'une robe ou d'un manteau ou
d'un bracelet ça je le crois pas mais
quand on dit ça je mets croatie officiel
pétrochimie très bons conseils te donner
l'asile où on parle à personne à
personne
je m'entends a personne tu en as permet
à personnes au moins non je l' ai juste
dit hazard fans à jaffa n'a malheureux
lavalas le cela qu'il fallait pas parler
un vrai transistors s'inquiète pas j'ai
beaucoup d' influence sur lui je vais le
voir je vais lui dire de se taire et
tout s'arrangera mais c'est le second -
ouais enfin jeudi à kuito aussi quand
vous aimez tiendrait qu'à la marque qu'à
huit haut parleurs qui marche 24 heures
sur 24 mais tu l'annoncé à tout plats
russes pas possible ça tu l'as dit à
george bush est aussi white lady tulle à
dire prospère le quartier ouais je lui
dis alors tu l'as dit aussi à 100 vers
le cordonnier et non il était fermé